okay
hello everybody
next morning thought
i'm 25 and in the manosphere
i should have been married like years
ago
what am i doing
so
i'm gonna just
give you guys a breakdown
of
why i'm not married
the t okay
so
i started
dating in college
um
i didn't lose my virginity till like
halfway through college
and it was to this guy that i was
obsessed with
for years
we were together like a year and then
it was like on and off like
thing
for years
so bad
so bad okay
that
i moved cities okay i moved cities i
moved from chicago to milwaukee
when i was 21
after college or maybe was i 22
i graduated college i was 22 when i
moved actually i was 22. i lied because
i did a super senior year at my college
i graduated in four years okay but i did
like a market research certification so
i could play basketball
so and then after that okay i moved to
milwaukee at 22.
and
in milwaukee
i was like traumatized so i didn't need
anyone for two years i'd go on like a
couple dates like here and there
but i literally did not have sex for two
years which is like kind of nuts
and then i met my last boyfriend
and and okay but that also wasn't just
because of the guy from college it was
also because i was supposed to go play
volleyball in london
and i was like
do i want to get in a relationship just
to leave
in a year like are we going to do
distance like what is that how is that
going to look
so then
partially but then i met my last
boyfriend
and my season got cancelled
dated him for a year
that didn't work out um
and i moved to
london
and like that that was a lot of it like
distance right
and we just weren't right for each other
anyway but
and then that ended in december and now
i'm here
and i'd like to i i always say try to
stay single half the length of the
relationship so that was a year
i'll maybe stay single till june
and then
i don't know we'll see what happens
after that
so
i don't know why why am i not married
maybe inability to pick
not a good picker
maybe
maybe me maybe like issues with me i'm
kind of anxious i'd say like
i do a lot in a relationship but very
much like people pleasey i think it
comes off a little strong i'm tired so
this is like very honest morning
thoughts
i don't know there's a lot of reasons
but if anyone was wondering why aren't i
married
that that is my
dating whatever and now it's like i'm
kind of in a similar situation because
it's like do i want to play pro in
germany do i want to stay in london
or i can move to a u.s city next year
if london gets too expensive
i'm a move in the fall
to a uh a cheaper u.s city
get a pro contract in germany where they
pay for my housing and do it there i
don't know
let me know what i should do in the
comments
anyways
bye